you know guys this is the first MCU
press screening I've ever been to where
they actually gave the audience a free
alcoholic beverage and you know what
that usually means for anyone who's been
to plenty of press
screenings when they're throwing a free
alcohol you you know how the studio
really feels about what they got on
their
hands what is going on there citizens of
the reject ation Greg and John here
today we just watched the marbles
Burbank is quite serious about any kind
of recording so we're going to have to
keep this quick and I'm glad we do
because I'm going to be very very direct
with you guys leave a like on this video
if you dare to John quickly give them
the plot if there is one that's an easy
task hey look there's this uh cre
Warrior who's real mad about the events
of Captain Marvel so she's searching out
uh you know various means of extracting
Revenge let's just put it that way
meanwhile Miss Marvel Kamala Khan Carol
daners Captain Marvel and Monica Rambo
they all discover uh that their powers
are interlined somehow all those
circumstances intertwin to where they
got to figure out what this weird power
switching thing is and how to stop the
villain that's kind of what it's about
okay all right I'm just going to give
you guys uh some quick thoughts here
Aman volani is easily the best part of
this whole movie to me I thought that
might be the case before watching this
film sure enough she is she steals every
scene she's in I like the appearance
from her family that is laced throughout
this entire film as well I thought they
were great John did you like Aman volani
very much so definitely she's great
right yep she is terrific Brie Larsson
boy have they made her relatable she is
Rel cracking wise she's having some fun
she's lightened up a bit I really like
Brie Larson individually quite a bit her
personality I thought she was much more
appealing this time around I quite
enjoyed all three of them yes
at least individually and often times
together and and Tiana Paris is another
terrific actor you know she's doing good
stuff with what they're giving her yes
yes I would say that too and the movie
occasionally has some cool visuals
occasionally there's some cool action
scenes I don't know about a whole scene
but there'll be moments within the
action like there's this whole thing
where whenever they use their powers or
switching spots with each other and
sometimes there's some really cool
choreography that happens there that is
the word that came to mind watching it I
was like there some cool inventive
choreography here and I thought
generally when it gave way to an action
scene which are often the scenes the
movie lets breathe the most you know
there's some pretty Punchy stuff in
there the music is occasionally good
it's much brighter in tone than I'm used
to from an MCU there were times where
I'm like oh we're going lighter we're
going more triumphant we're going
something that reminds me more of I
don't know why Danny Alman but kind of
listen guys when this movie was done KY
was sitting next to me and everyone
knows KY is the guy who's the most
forgiving of the MCU he looked at me
and I don't want to just give away his
review I'm going to say it right now
though because I could not agree more he
said this is not what Marvel needs right
now fair
I really tried to like this movie the
first I'd say 20 to 30 minutes of it I
was like all right it's edited a little
weird tastes a little funny it looks
like a TV show but I'm having fun it's
messy but I'm having fun but then
eventually for me seems like you're a
lot nicer about it than me and I'm
totally okay I don't want to run
anyone's parade we went to a screening
where there's a mixed bag there there's
a lot of people who really liked it and
good for you if you really like it for
me I think this is one of the worst MCU
movies that they have ever done and I
was really trying because I think these
three actresses while great they
deserved a much better movie than this
and sure is there an end credit scene
and a post credit scene that is so
important to the future of the MCU abs
absolutely and I would advise not
letting the importance of what it is
setting up disuade you into thinking
that what you just watched is a great
film because it's not in fact there are
things about the post credit scene that
actively OBS I I buried my head and I
can't I I think I said out loud like I
can't believe they just there's one
choice they make about it where I could
not believe that they did it in the
post-credit scene specifically the movie
itself I thought was terribly edited
throughout terribly pasted I felt
nothing I thought the movie was in a
rush to finish they reaches a rush to do
anything it sets its mind to it goes in
and out of scenes that are supposed to
have emotion John was on my right cor on
left turn like what is happening right
now like why are they just like speeding
through it I think it is the worst comic
book movie I have seen all year I don't
like the first Captain Marvel movie that
one at least feels like an actual movie
this felt like they took an entire
season's worth of a Disney Plus show
crammed it into 2 and 1/2 hours and then
said 2 and 1/2 hours is too long we got
to trim it down to an hour and 40
minutes I do not think this is a good
movie
and I'm not apologizing for it it's not
a good movie great actors in it some
good action Samuel Jackson looks bored
as [__] does not feel like the
performance carrying over from Secret
Invasion whatsoever I mean I can Abide a
lighter toned Fury and even lack of
continuity from characterization I know
comic books will do that but but yeah
it's a bit disconcerting the way they
handled Nick Fury throughout a lot of
the comedy is done through this like
lacad isical we don't really care kind
of attitude that casual like well that's
kind of weird sort of Comedy yeah Marvel
released this trailer the final one for
the Marvels it is not that tone I
guarantee you there are some scenes in
this movie that are some of the
cheesiest cringiest scenes you will ever
see in any of the MCU and I feel so bad
for what some of these actors are going
to be going through because of the movie
they deliver when it is not their fault
they're great and they're giving it
their all and I really [__] mean that
it's weird and messy at times it gets to
a point where like I think it's maybe
intentional I can see someone
surrendering to the mess and just going
whatever I'm having fun with it it's a
fantasy chaos I feel like I got to say
something nice there's some cat stuff in
on I'm like I'm a cat lover look I've
chocked up a lot of movies of my
experience of going like yeah it's messy
and whatever but I had fun this is one
of those experiences where the mess just
overrode the fun for me John please say
nice things because you're on a much
higher note than I am about it all right
yes I mean I I was having some kind of a
blast throughout a lot of this movie it
certainly is all over the place it is a
very much and then kind of a plot where
just random things will pop up and they
don't really give much time to pay
attention to them however the color and
the levity of everything and the sort of
bounciness had me enjoying myself for a
good amount of it there is a Crossroads
I think you will come to as a viewer
depending on how much that enjoyment is
bolstering your experience where it may
kind of plateau and sort of drop off for
you or it'll start to make you mad I am
in the camp where I was always kind of
pleasantly enjoying it sometimes
genuinely sometimes sort of in spite of
the strange cacophony this movie becomes
I don't begrudge a Marvel movie feeling
a bit like a cartoon a bit disconnected
in terms of like the immediacy of the
continuity stuff like that is cool when
it happens but I'm not hanging on that
so a lot of this I was like cool as long
as this is a fun colorful sort of
bonding experience with just enough
Stakes I'm happy the trouble for me is
that you don't really get much chance to
lch on to any of the stakes no no no for
sure like I thought um I I'm blanking on
the actress's name zawe something or
other the villain yes oh my God what a
terrible villain whatever her name is
terrible villain she's another one of
those villains that isy to have a very
capable actor do all of the work to make
this any kind of character looking
badass very underwritten the main three
I don't think that this movie is really
bolstering their Journey as characters
again I'm not asking these movies to be
the deepest I'm not asking for some kind
of impactful meaningful allegory however
there are character threads that are
meaningful that would help this movie be
more enjoyable us enjoy and love these
characters that much more based on
something other than pre-existing
knowledge that they leave on the table
there are opportunities for the history
between Carol and and and uh Monica to
be rectified that are touched upon but
not really unpacked and those things are
the saddest parts of the movie to me
because there are lots of opportunities
for some actual impactful character work
they do not take I felt kind of bad when
the credit started to roll cuz I was
like I don't think this is really any of
the creative fault I doubt this is what
any of those three writers wanted this
movie to look like I doubt this is
exactly the calling card Nia wanted out
of this experience everybody for the
most part shows up but it is like a
weird episode of do it's like one of
those Doctor Who episodes that is like a
loud mess and sometimes those are fun
and in this case I had fun with that but
sometimes those are grading and not fun
and I feel like it's just as valid to
fall on that other side basically at a
certain point it does start to plateau
and then you start to notice the defici
genes of the actual plotting film making
characterization Etc that keep this from
succeeding despite the aspects that are
maybe a bit messy I mean I don't
begrudge anyone who ends up actually
liking this movie I did not have high
expectations for this movie somehow it
came in exceedingly under what I
expected out of this movie and I think
that the directing on this is not really
shown well like you hear these reports
coming out like this does not feel like
Nea to cost's Direction I can't even get
my thought to death it feels Studio
noted to death it's the one of the most
comedi made Marvel movies I've seen in a
very very long time it feels like
somebody panicked and they're like this
has to make up for so much and also be
the next huge installment and set up all
the important [__] to come and I think
it buckles under the weight of not just
choosing one and being that I think
these characters and these actors they
deserved a much better film for sure The
Sisterhood deserves better they really
did because they're not the problem with
this movie at all they're not they're
the only thing that kind of saves the
film at times with the occasional cool
visual moment but most of the time I'm
like I don't even care what's happening
on screen it feels like such an an
impassive experience honestly that's my
thoughts on it I'm kind of baffled by
how much I didn't like it I'm like a 2.5
to three out of 10 on this film I'm more
like a six you know like I had enough
fun I have fun uh but yeah there's a lot
of ways this could have been great and
really enjoyable and heart swelling all
right let me edit this video so I can
get bunch of crap from everyone who
already sold their minds on whether they
liked it that's it thanks for being here
see you see you soon cnx
[Music]
Marvel